[Music]
bit about me Sam Sam
I'm based out of Milwaukee I'm a custom
engineer with Google cloud and my main
client is calls which is one of the
reasons why I'm speaking of Kohl's and
this simple fact about Milwaukee I was
driving on Monday and on the radio they
actually said Milwaukee hadn't reached
70 degrees Fahrenheit for 180 days so
that gives you an indication as to how
cold that place is I just thought I
should share that with you see ya so edw
migration journey no it's a couple of
quick things I forget started because
I'm gonna forget to say that at the end
of it at the end of the recession you
know if you have questions please come
up to the microphone right here alright
so we can all hear you and the second is
there's also survey that you'll love for
you to fill out so if you could do that
after the session that we much
appreciate it right so the problem
statement you know why are we here today
you're trying to talk about how do you
take your your data warehouse
you know on-prem and move to the cloud
with sort of minimal disruption all
right make sure you still have security
and make sure that all your teams get as
productive as possible as quickly as
possible right there's certain elements
to this you know and obviously this is
not going to hold for everybody but it's
it and broad strokes you can look at you
know so for instance you know you have
to look at speedo adoption right and one
of the key things they said if you a
bunch of people sitting around and you
know things go offline well you know it
can cause significant disruptions to
your business right so can you get this
up quickly can you get it running
quickly all right and can they be
productive as quickly as possible
you know then scale you know how do you
scale as needed like how do you scale
elastically so as I mentioned you know
Kohl's is my customer right it's in the
retail space you have a certain
seasonality of data no certain
seasonality of needs of data
and can your data warehouse help you
manage that in other words can you scale
appropriately and that's really
important because you also to maintain
you know not only should you be
productive with the data but you should
also be able to you know manage your
costs right insights analysis you know
how quickly can you because when you
moving your your data warehouse all
right from one frame to cloud will you
have certain processes already in place
to help you be productive with that data
right so you know can you move those
workloads over quickly efficiently and
make sure that you know you can also
empower new kinds of workloads right so
something more modern comes along or
something more let's say you are diving
into the AI space you know can your new
data warehouse you know help you deliver
on those workloads right and security is
paramount right so you want to make sure
that only people have access to the data
all right should have access to the data
you want to make sure that you know that
the needs of your end-users also are met
all right so privacy is maintained and
you know these are sort of the broad
strokes and comes to what you need to
consider when moving your data warehouse
say to the cloud you know so most of you
are here in the room because you
probably have some at least you know
familiarity but how many W works right
so this is more of a just sort of a
level set right you know you know what
is the easiest way to think of data
warehouses you know think of it as your
central repository we can just dump a
whole bunch of data in so that you can
be you can derive insights out of it
right now what it means in terms of the
you know in terms of particular will
different systems system but in general
that's the intent of data warehouse
right who's it meant to serve that
depends on your organization but in
general you know your budget analysts
you have business leaders you have
people of differing needs who need to
get insights out of the data right was
it wasn't supposed to enable well
fundamentally it's a driver of business
right that's the key requirement of you
know collecting the data and analyzing
the it in the first place
right so you cannot keep you know that
is one of the first things that you
gotta keep in mind is that how do you
enable business decisions
to be made yeah and what can look like
well so I got a bunch of arguments with
a whole bunch of people about what does
the you know what does it represent of
the slide for this so you know none of
us could decide as to you know a common
theme so we decided you know what let's
go to the magic of Wikipedia right and
you know where a whole bunch of other
people can argue about it and come up
with something that is rather simple you
know as you can see you got a bunch of
data on the left-hand side all right
gets into stage in kind of area all
right and gets ingested and you have
sort of different data mods which are
aligned to specific business needs right
and you have sort of different purposes
that those data marts into and conserve
so yeah it's it's sort of again large
role into data right that you wrangle
get into a central area all right and
now that can be piped through to serve
different business needs and different
people can sort of gain different
insights out of it make different
business decisions out of it so now you
know we talked about just what an e GW
is right and one of the big reasons that
we are talking about why do you want to
you know move to the cloud well there
are some reasons for it because if there
weren't any issues or challenges right
you wouldn't need to sort of do the
migration the first place right so one
of the first things that we have to deal
with in today's world is that the amount
of data and the kinds of data you're
dealing with is rapidly changing so not
only do you have to accommodate for the
amount of data but you know the sub the
kinds of data and the speed at which is
ingested right now one way of handling
this is sort of all provision on your
data warehouse right this is the
seasonality of the data actually has a
significant impact because if you over
scale a right to to handle those spikes
well now you're stuck with a bunch of
infrastructure sitting around that is
underutilized most of the time which is
not efficient the other way is you under
provision and say let's just ignore the
spikes and that's not going to work
either
right you know it's a responsive to the
needs right how does it add app you know
as you have more and more people coming
in say with different ideas right and
the only try out stuff
you know can your data warehouse
accommodate their needs as well all
right can it
you know can it be faster can you
produce your reports faster so that
people can make decisions faster all
right
different kinds of workloads all right
so in some cases you're you know let's
let's say that you doing a bunch of
aggregate analysis great but in some
cases say you want to you know create a
new data set out of it that is more
suitable to it's a machine learning
alright so can it actually you know
accommodate that the other thing that
I've seen in the field is this that it's
sort of a victim of zone success
you know when you when you bring all the
data and you you know you go in and you
make the significant investment and now
you have this you know this central
repository that is enabling all these
business decisions well the expectation
is that it continues to do that over
time right and now suddenly two years
down the road you say you know we need
more capacity or we need you know it's
no longer providing the kind of results
that we're used to you know so it's
almost as if you know it it was
transformational but because now the
expectations so high it's hard to sort
of keep up you know especially in sort
of a staticky kind of setup that a
traditional on-premise gonna be right
and then which goes to you know kind of
meet our needs two three five years from
now you know are you gonna have the same
conversations over and over again with
your business leader saying oh we need
more capacity oh we can't run these
workloads we can't you know it like can
it still deliver over time alright and
these are some of the common refrains
that we see in the field all the time
which is why you know I would like to
now bring in cold jazz from Kohl's who
went through this you know in real life
so thank you Sam first of all my
introduction I am just when they're
saying I'm a senior manager of big data
analytics at Kohl's and thank you Sam
for reminding that we have to go back to
the 40 degree weather after enjoying the
70 degree weather over here so so most
of the enterprises the analytical
ecosystem has been built over past
several years and over the years we have
collected different systems and more
recently in the last few years most of
the companies have also added Big Data
and Hadoop to their ecosystem so let's
kind of talk about why did we even need
so many systems to start with so the
main factor was cost so as we kind of
brought in these kind of technical
stacks and they had kind of fixed
capacity so so we based on the cost and
based on our use cases we bought some
fixed capacity and as we started working
through the years the capacity was not
enough because we needed to solve more
and more use cases and so we ended up
bringing more of these monolithic
solutions and and some of the solutions
that were brought in were for our
technical capabilities so some of the
use cases needed a different system to
be brought in so at the end of the day
we had data coming in from our source
systems and landing in two different
warehousing systems and since we could
not bring in data into a single system
we basically had the need of exchanging
data between the system so a lot of data
was being copied across these systems
and at the end of the day we had
basically arrows going in every
direction that you can imagine so just
to kind of highlight what are the issues
that we deal with
in architecture like this we had
disparate data sources for enterprise
use we had inconsistent analysis and
decisions were inconsistent because the
data was in different systems and as it
was copied from one system to another
system some of the data quality things
were also kind of having issues with it
was kind of difficult to access the data
across different platforms so let's say
you needed data from two of the systems
and I have to build a report the only
way I could do that is basically copy
the data from one system to other system
and also it was very difficult to
understand the other level data within
these systems and if you're looking for
data it was kind of a scavenger hunt and
there is like very few people in the
enterprise who know where to get the
data from and the other problem that we
were having was that there was no common
understanding of the definitions and the
measurements of the data within the
warehousing systems so overall we had a
big opportunity that we could basically
go for and solve it in our future use
cases so in our traditional warehousing
system we have these characteristics
that are kind of limitation so so you
can see on the on the left hand side we
we had to as we brought in data into our
ecosystem we had to structure it first
and the reason we had to structure it
first is because we cannot just bring in
anything and everything and and the
reason being it is basically fixed
capacity so there was a lot of time
spent upfront to structure the data
before we ingested it and brought it for
the analytical purposes and over the
years as I said right we brought these
monolithic stacks and as we are working
through different use cases one one
stack would not
solve the problem so we had to bring in
some other stack to kind of solve the
the newer use cases so at the end of the
day we had some of our challenges on
Prem were we had a very complex
operations in our data center
data centers we had these multiple
stacks which were kind of distracting to
each other exchanging data and and it
was kind of becoming more complex for us
to kind of support in our data center
and and even with all of these different
stacks it was very difficult to keep up
with the data growth so our new approach
or the new way of delivering the
warehouse is that we are going with kind
of a flexible structure where we can get
in any kind of data so we can basically
get in structured data or
semi-structured or unstructured data and
we can ingest it and then analyze it and
then structure it based on our means and
the ecosystem will be with dynamic
capacity so we can add capacity as
needed and it is kind of an ecosystem
which which is enabled by the bunch of
services which can basically solve all
our use cases rather than just moving
the data from one system to other system
so so in terms of advantages we
basically had a faster speed to market
we basically enable a bunch of services
and we were able to quickly stand up and
deliver some value our our new approach
is elastic and also managed so that we
don't have to deal with all these
complex infrastructure operations
so here is how we are planning to build
the single source of truth in the in the
Google Cloud bigquery so this is
basically cools data Lake in Vic query
so so as you can see we have different
systems on the left-hand side similar to
what we had before and we have data
coming in it can be any kind of data but
it's a batch or real-time and we are
assembling all of the data in Google
bakery and and and then making the data
available for all of our use cases here
so some of the benefits of using an
architecture like this is we have
basically a single source of truth and
all the analytical use cases are driving
the value from the single warehouse in
the query so also using this
architecture we have enabled
self-service so we have provided the
decision-makers with easy access and
readily available data which is secure
and clean we along with clean data we
have provided our business users with
some data discovery and visualization
tools which will help them with speeding
up the decision process and since the
team is not busy with just copying the
data from one system to other system we
have started focusing on some of the
advanced analytics we have started
shifted from structured reporting to
kind of more actionable insights and
predictive analytics and since as you
can see the data is in a single system
we are now standardizing the business
metadata and the attributes and the
metrics across the organization so our
approach for building this has been very
simple so we have been building a
parallel environment in Google by
channeling all of our existing sources
that are going into the traditional
warehouse today and channeling them to
go into bigquery so as we bring and land
all of the data into bigquery we are
working with our business partners and
prioritizing how they would like to kind
of cleanse and start using the data if
within bigquery
so so I think so as we kind of kind of
bring the data and we kind of cleanse it
make it have a label we have started to
solve certain use cases that are that
were being solved with our previous
solution as well but now we are able to
solve some other use cases which totally
needed a different stack like marketing
operations is also leveraging this stack
and also recommendations can also
leverage the stack so and and and as we
are delivering the data we are also
doing some comparison between on-prem
and cloud and we have tools that that we
have built to kind of showcase that the
data which we are which we are
assembling in bigquery is higher quality
and also it is delivered with lesser
amount of time and it can be leveraged
for analytics plus other use cases as
well so here is the the logical
architecture slide that we have been
using so so going from on bottom to the
top we have different sources of data
coming in we have external data sources
and we have internal data sources so we
are landing the data using either like
file transports or reading real time
that flume or getting it into Kafka and
we are landing all of the data into a
big query staging area where we are
applying some transformation logic some
of the business logic and making the
data available in the certified data
sets and in some cases we might be
creating some
enterprise reporting structures which
are being leveraged by the different
reporting tools so I think the key key
thing here is that all of this is being
done in bigquery so we are not really
leveraging a lot of other tools to
deliver the data although you can see
that we do have a little bit of data
proc and that is being leveraged for
some advanced or transformation use
cases or certain use cases where we have
to protect the data differently so we do
have some data proc and spark that we
are leveraging for that but generally
speaking those use cases are less than
5% so using this architecture we are
basically enabling faster access to the
data for Kol's analytical communities we
have increased the speed and efficiency
of the data delivery and also since it
is a single kind of stack it is very
easy to facilitate the governance and
ensure the data quality and we are using
data security using some of the
encryption that bigquery provides and
also managing access using the
fine-grained access control that are in
bigquery
so overall this is kind of standardizing
the data architecture across schools
analytical communities
so at a high level the data that we are
bringing into our warehouse is primarily
real-time sources or it is kind of the
bad sources that are coming in so so in
case of the bad sources we basically
land the data in in Google storage in
the raw state and as I as I discussed in
my previous slide
most of the data can directly go into
bigquery and in some cases we are using
some spark and it's a lightweight
application which can help it with
certain PII elements protection
converting the formats if the formats
are not ready for bigquery or converting
it to a different file format so once
the data is loaded into raw and you can
see a similar pipeline on the top where
we have streaming data coming in from
the sources whether they are read
through api's or these are pushed into
our koepcke kind of infrastructure and
we have a spark streaming application
which is using the bigquery streaming
API and landing the data in draw in a
streaming fashion and bickering so once
the data is all in the raw we are
combining the data set creating the gold
structures or the certified data sets
and once the data is available in the
gold data sets it is available for
different use cases whether it is the
data scientists who are who are
basically pulling the data using some PI
spark jobs using BQ storage api's or we
have extracts that are being run through
a spark job or there are some reporting
use cases which we are enabling on
tableau and all the ad hoc analytics is
basically happening on on bickering
so to kind of summarize here so so this
talks about some of the challenges that
we were having with our own Prem
solution so we have like with our
current one Prem solution where we had a
dupe and we had Erie W ecosystems we had
a very complex operations and then that
kind of and also with that kind of
complex operations we were unable to
keep up with the data growth and we were
having issues with data latency due to
the data moving across various systems
we had very we had a very complex
implementation since we had kind of a
zoo of technologies and no common
approaches it was very difficult to kind
of just manage the the ecosystem data
was hard to understand and the data was
kind of the data quality was suffering
because it was going through multiple
hops and the data existed in kind of
multiple systems and our infrastructure
cost was really high because there was
lot of duplication that was happening so
so the advantages of doing the this in
the cloud
bigquery ecosystem is that we we don't
have any upfront cost and as we need
kind of as we are adding more and more
to bigquery we are adding more capacity
to our bigquery infrastructure and it is
so we kind of leverage the the fixed
slots within Cowles so we started off at
certain number of slots and as we are
kind of growing a storage is not a
problem but as we need more and more
compute we are working with our Google
and we we are able to bring in more
slots as these it needed so so it's kind
of faster speed to market because of use
usage of the cloud services and also as
we are bringing in data we have created
some reusable component
and functions that can help with file
management or auditing or auditing so
those are kind of just everything is a
template for us so as we bring in more
and more data we just use a standard
template and we bring in all the all the
data and some of those standard
functions are being used the solution is
elastic from both compute and storage
standpoint and it is hosted by Google so
with that I bring Sam back to the podium
again
hello so thanks jazz as you can see you
know he has the breath and sort of depth
of expertise in managing data at scale
for a really large retailer and I've
been fortunate to you know be part of
that journey and I've seen you know how
complex it can be sometimes can be
overwhelming all right you have tons of
different moving parts and you have
something already in place so the the
the ante is really high right is that
you're going from something that is
functional yes you may not be extremely
satisfied with it and you're trying to
move all of that to a completely
different you know system altogether
without disrupting business so you know
it's this is I say you know what just
happened right because there was a lot
of moving parts there right and in my
experience with working jazz and his
team you know the you know how do you
take a monumental task like this and in
our discussions you know he had a very
insightful we were discussing it or
describing it this is a generational
event it doesn't happen all the time
right so when you are there this is not
this is going to be the once in a
generation event that you're gonna take
something your existing data warehouse
and move it to the cloud so it is
complex overwhelming you have a lot of
different people and you know you have
to get buy-in from a whole bunch of
people how do you how do you manage that
you know obviously leverage your
accounting right this is where people
like me come in you know we can help out
all right if nothing else when you get
frustrated can just yell at me that's
cool but you know it it comes down to
this right the first thing is you have
to decide to move right it is a decision
that has to you have to be firm about it
rightly yeah it's not about you what you
think you know let's go for it
all right you know you have to get
stakeholder buy-in right that's one of
the in a complex transformation like
this you need to get buy-in across the
board right so that is key you know then
one of the things that I saw Jazz's team
do is you go through diligently and
identifying all the data sources
auditing it making sure that they all
makes sense right figuring out you know
how what does the code is going to look
like in say Bitcoin because the
use bigquery as sort of the central
pillar of their daily strategy going
forward all right then the simplest
thing is identify a chunk all right go
to plc route you know so that you can
get first of all it allows your team to
get comfortable with the new sort of
semantics new technology new paradigms
that involve in Pickering right and you
know build upon it it allows you to you
know sort of reimagine what your data
barrels is gonna be in Google Cloud
right and if obviously execute and I've
seen them execute on this and flawlessly
right it has been complex but his team
has done an awesome job on this so in
one of the previous slides I said you
know what are the broad strokes that you
need to consider when you are moving
your data warehouse to the cloud right
doctor speedo adoption so this is big
fairy right this is our solution to help
you you know be data informed at scale
all right
so speed adoption you know bigquery you
know you can get you can get up and
running very quickly all right if your
analysts are very comfy using sequel go
for it it's available for you all right
as jazz mentioned you know scaling as
needed right so they started off with a
bunch of fixed slots and as their
capacity needs started increasing they
started increasing the number of slots
available to them so you know they could
scale as needed
insights analysis again they moved over
some of the existing scripts some of the
existing workloads and they're
productive as quickly as possible and
they also unlocked more workloads right
and they're able to deliver on this
faster right over much more amounts of
data all right and you know it's also
opening up you know and this is a
nothing little bit Craig right is that
ml is getting more and more important so
be qml if you're not familiar with it
out highly recommend looking into it it
allows you to excuse machine learning
models on the query itself which is very
cool right and security you know
encryption at rest in flight and you
know you know very fine-grained access
controls using I am and with this you
know some customers go ahead and do it
on their own they have their deep
expertise their teams are built out they
can actually pull this on their own and
sometimes you know you need additional
help
all right and this is why NJTV we allow
you we try to help you figure out you
know what is the best approach you can
take it sometimes you need a partner
right and this is where I would look in
two years dr. Phil who is the present
date America thanks Sam thanks jazz - so
let's get into migrating data warehouses
so why moved to GCP you've already
covered a lot of that there's some very
good reasons to move analytics workload
of GCP its best-in-class in all of you
BQ is a killer app and I think many of
you know about it already but moving a
large data warehouse has some risks and
challenges to the business the business
can be clearly severely damaged if you
screw up the migration of a data
warehouse you're gonna know about it
pretty quickly so we started years ago
moving these things manually but you
take a large complex data warehouse or
an infrastructure like jazz presented
it's extremely complex to understand the
data flows contingencies
interdependences and to move that
manually is it's risky because you can
move a little piece and then break the
rest of it in the process so we started
to figure out how do we move this in a
more automated fashion quite a few years
ago and then how do we stay out who
actually manage this is a very slide
sorry about it so wordy but you can take
your time to read it but really the
reason to go to slide 2 to cloud is the
unlimited scalability the flexibility of
performance you get the ability to bring
in all the different data sets streaming
real-time IOT batch structured
unstructured in any sequence any format
you want in any sense speed of latency
that you need and putting all your data
in a single point of truth there's no
question we all know that's logical
sensible very helpful and is definitely
the direction that we're all going the
fast pace of features that are being
added you see constantly the
announcements that next here new
features coming all the time there's no
way you can anyone else can compete with
the speed of cloud vendors in
at the moment then the new capabilities
are coming every few weeks and because
you're on one platform now with the data
in a single point of truth place you can
start to adopt those tools as they come
along and then you can focus as Jaz said
you can focus more on the actual
workload innovation how do you drive
value from the data rather than worrying
about running servers headaches of data
centers blowing up in the middle of the
night which Keith and I had a few years
ago it's it's just getting you out of
that headache and focusing on the value
from your from your data and and adopt
these new tools as they come so cost is
a big play right so we starting to talk
about large tower data appliances of you
know 20 million dollars plus each in
some cases you know five to six years
life 20% annual maintenance on top of
that massive costs of buying and
acquiring and then all the people to run
that so the cost advantages of moving to
cloud are pretty significant we often do
cost calculations for companies early on
to show the cost benefit and in the
larger data warehouses we see up to 60s
almost 70 percent in some cases
five-year cost savings even in their
small ones we see 20 to 30 percent cost
savings so going to cloud is very
powerful and I'm gonna come back on that
in a little while and then you pay for
what you use of course also we want to
eliminate a lot of this legacy ETL we've
had ETL around for 30 years or more in
some cases it's very batch wise thinking
it's not the modern way of dealing with
data IOT streaming just mentioned that
the way we're going is real-time
Enterprise streaming is happening it's
something we have to embrace because the
old ETL mentality is is really holding
us back so we want to eliminate a lot of
legacy to yell at the same time and we
want to be more labor efficient so
common challenges when you want to move
for data warehouse that you have to
address internally is no budget and cost
of course it's gonna cost something to
move you will be paid back within a year
or two or three but most typically you
will see a payback some
even in a single year you'll see payback
especially for your data warehouses
end-of-life if it's about to be
end-of-life the ROI on moving is very
powerful usually less than a year
payback so how'd you get started what
are the steps how did you get your data
there know not only how did you get the
data there but how did you keep it
synchronized because this is a moving
train right your existing system is live
there's data flowing all the time it's
changing so you can't just take a
snapshot and move it and expect it to
work it doesn't work like that so how do
you move it all and how do you keep it
all synchronized and it can't take years
to do this because nobody has the
patience to do a big multi-year project
anymore it has to take weeks and months
so those are the challenges you'll see
so we started to develop years ago some
tools around that first of all how do
you assess how do you plan and assess
this I can you know if you all here have
a data warehouse I can pretty much
guarantee you don't know everything
that's running on your data warehouse
there is jobs ETL jobs transformation
jobs user jobs there's data being
ingested I can promise you you don't
know and you have not documented
everything that's running on your system
so how can you move it if you don't know
what's running so we have we developed a
tool it's a machine learning based tool
that discovers everything I mean
literally everything that's running on
an environment so in a very fine-grain
detail and then it uses the clustering
algorithm to cluster pieces of workload
together so you move a cluster at a time
in a sprint model the next piece is how
do you convert all the code right you
can't just typically lift and shift a
code code base from a data warehouse so
if you took Tara date or it may have m
loads it might have sequel for users it
might have BTech scripts it might have
ETL scripts that are non-standard sequel
and you're going to put them onto BQ to
run or on spark or whatever on cloud
they have to be converted in some cases
so rarely can you almost never can you
lift and shift a data warehouse with all
of the workload without some conversion
so how do you automate that conversion
how would you convert different dialects
of sequel to a standardized BQ sequel
sparks equal so again we have to
automate that then how do you move the
data right so how do you move how do you
replace that ETL how do you replace the
data pipelines how do we make that a
more seamless parametrically driven
exercise and finally how do you validate
the data as you're in transition you've
got data in one data warehouse that's a
live system you've now got data on the
in cloud and you've got to run in
parallel for a period of time because
you need to know those two systems match
you need to know that your new system is
giving you exactly the same results as
the old system with the same data inputs
you're getting the same data outputs
because your business users won't let
you switch over until each phase is
validated so validation is is a huge
challenge that we've automated that as
well
so combining those tools we can now do a
sprint based approach we can now break a
data warehouse down into many small
sprints well we can run each sprint in
parallel on both systems for a period of
time and only move those users over for
that sprint when we are confident that
both systems are matching the data is
matching the queries are matching the
outputs are matching and performance is
at least matching and so when we've done
that we can move it and move the next
sprint and the next sprint so it's not a
big bang lift and shift anymore because
that's way too difficult too scary we
want to break it down into Sprint's and
now we can do that costs are they really
lower people ask that you know Hadoop
was pretty cheap for storage on premise
but of course we're now dealing with
storage on cloud of between 1 and 3
cents per gigabyte per month and getting
lower all the time and that is
impossible to match with any on-site
storage that I know of the separation of
compute and storage so we now have
storage that's very low cost we can
bring different compute engines we can
bring BQ we can bring spark we can bring
Python we can bring whatever compute
engines we want to the same copy of data
on the same storage and the storage is
low cost so there are significant cost
savings if in a well structured like
jazz this new architecture is you know
perfect example of a very clean simple
architecture single point of truth on
the low-cost storage and bringing any
compute engine to that that you need and
that's the way to go so the promise is
to take the frustration and cost out of
these migrations and the anxiety of
these large migrations so you may have
thousands of what you will have in some
case many thousands of users using these
legacy systems we have to move them
without all the anxiety and that's why
we approach this in this sort of sprint
way
sprin ways process so we want to
optimize it we want to automate it we
want to use the tools to do the
conversion of code we want to do the
automated tools for doing the validation
and the data migration we in the right
at the bottom we want to run in parallel
reduce risk in errors and mistakes that
is the only way we know of moving these
large environments successfully so the
targets of this level of automation are
here on the right clearly a lot of
teradata the terminators the most
expensive of course data warehouse and
moving that has of the biggest ROI of
all of them the teaser if you're in an
T's a custom you know the IBM has
end-of-life support on a lot in the
teaser machines at the moment it's a lot
of people wanting to move in a teaser
Oracle of course and Hadoop is still as
Jaz mentioned there's a lot of Hadoop
that needs to be moved and even the old
db2 and greenplum so as a lot of these
tools have been written to automate the
migration of these to cloud and all the
associated pieces of ETL so their time
efficiency now through automation we're
seeing about the two-thirds reduction in
cost in cost and time time particularly
because we can automate a lot of this
automate the assessment order make the
migration automated validation and do it
in a sprint wise process and about about
50% cost saving or a little more
sometimes so now we now we can move
things quicker and see the benefits that
you saw from the Kohl's example so we're
going to do some Q&A in a minute I think
those Sam you want to come back for a
minute
yep so you know X dr. Phil no as you can
see that you know when we started off
right we talked about a customer was
able to set it deliver on their own and
sometimes you need a partner
right some of the key points that stood
out in what dr. Phil just said you know
one is automation all right a lot of
this is dependent automation like can
you get things to be reliable and can be
done sort of quicker right
the other was validation like how do you
validate whether you've been successful
or not so those are two really important
points and the third is he did mention
crashing data warehouses so that is
definitely scary
so bring it all together right so when I
started off you know when I try to you
know distill what jazz had just said
about especially their approach right
you know we talked about deciding to
move getting stakeholder by and
identifying all that all data sources
POC execute well that's a start
right this is the next sort of steps
that are gonna take right move
historical data over point your sources
you know directly GCP in this case
update your tools and reports the point
to be Q you know evaluate performance
all right the benchmark it make sure
that you're getting identical results
across adding identical data sets and
yes to an off on from you DW because
that was the goal at the beginning of it
right you know and keep building and
making great things so you know it's
complex it's intense and I've seen this
you know happen all right but it's
doable
I mean prime examples you know dr. phil
has helped a lot of people you know move
over I've seen Kohl's move over as well
so it's definitely doable
it just takes effort all right so you're
going to go in a Q&A section right now
I'm going to act as a moderator
right so if you have any questions
please feel free to step up to the mic
and we can you know answer your
questions
somebody turned that mic on
hi yes words I have a question for date
emetic if I pronounce this correctly can
you address a little bit is that a
static workload migration that you do
and how do you deal with context
information so for example we've seen a
lot of query differences that are only
there because certain data types are
there and certain transformations need
to be applied one that is true so it's
not always possible to do you know just
to create to query B type of rewrite but
rather it needs to be run in the context
that the original query was run and if
you had to do that or if you had to deal
with that how many times did you have to
actually manually go and help the system
right right and also the data model may
need to change in some cases right
because you're coming from schemas on
data warehouses where they're not very
friendly to these big data environments
so there may be very high numbers of
joins they may be concurrent reads and
writes going on at high volumes so there
are some changes that have to be done to
both code and data model and and user
queries in some cases I would say that
that's getting less and less they need
to make changes as going down quite
quite quickly now because the early days
of the cloud tools they were not
tolerant at all of some of the data
structures and schemas they were on data
warehouses now now they BQ particularly
is advanced a lot so we we're seeing
less and less changes to make the same
workload move without changing schemas
and code but if of course if you want if
you do want to change something that you
changed the format's of data the schemes
of data and there may be performance
tuning with there is a little bit of
manual work so you know we it's not it
depends on it depends
so sometimes it's highly automated
sometimes it's 25% or so manual work of
cleanup but it's very workload as
dependent but the degree of changes
we're seeing is going down as BQ becomes
more tolerant
I think sometimes is just legacy stuff
that nobody
of the modern systems we'll implement so
those will always have to be dealt with
there is some manual work this is not
entirely automated thank you another one
hard to see somebody's coming down maybe
two maybe three George hi hi thanks for
the presentation I'm curious to know
about the end-user experience the types
of tools
how many end-users did you have to
support in the conversion what their
tool compatibility experience was and
then my second question would be what
you're experiencing at estimating slot
counts and what you thought it would be
versus what your forecast is gonna be
talking about the slot counts right so
there is a calculator that Google has
which basically helps you look at your
current on-prem systems and come up with
some kind of an estimate if you run a
similar workload in the cloud this is
how much it will take to run it again
you should take that with a grain of
salt because sometimes these numbers are
really big in some cases and we will
basically we started off with certain
use cases and work with Google and said
if we have to do certain workloads
how much do you think it will basically
be on those slots so we started off with
that and we started to bring in more and
more use cases and add to those slots so
we have not started off with a very big
number so we are going with a with a
smaller number and at this point so like
halfway done through the migration I
think we are kind of trending towards
kind of just getting to a number which
is going to add a lot of value to our
final migration in terms of cost and
then my first part was about the I guess
the end-user tools and the types of
tools that you've moved on to the
platform like you know tableau and
MicroStrategy and what that experience
was did you have to rewrite reports to
take advantage of the new data model or
did they come over more see
mostly yeah I think the approach has
been that we don't want to just simply
lift and shift whatever we have in the
club whatever we have on Prem because
that's going to be very difficult to
support in a longer run because the data
is in six normal form or its kind of you
know kind of normalized in some of our
systems as we bring it on we're trying
to normalize it D normalize it as much
as we can and there is a change that is
that we are asking our partners and
business stakeholders to make as we are
moving to the cloud so in terms of duals
yes we have brought in some of our
reporting tools to the cloud and making
that available and we have also enabled
a lot of tools which will enable
self-service on the cloud and data prep
is one of the examples where we
basically provide certified data sets to
our stakeholders and let them have it
from there right they can create their
own structures and create the reporting
that they need eventually from that
questions a lot of new wave migrations
they were trying to keep the same data
model and same tools because change
management on the human side is the
biggest issue so what we do is that is
entirely possible
but there's usually an optimization
phase afterwards where things are not
working well there's some long running
queries some issues so there's a tuning
[Music]